hello and welcome to the new order of
your source for everything anime and
manga and today we are here for some
grand speculation because i would like
to
as best we can determine the net
affinity of one
paristan hill but before we get into it
we are going to be playing a bit of a
game with this exploration because
i want you yes you to guess what my
conclusion is going to be
before the end of the video so please do
make your prediction in the comments
below right now do you think paristan
will be an
enhancer transmuter manipulator
emitocondra or specialist
and if your prediction is wrong then
your punishment will be to subscribe to
the new world review which will
admittedly grant you regular hunt onto
content uploaded straight into your
youtube feed
so i think it's pretty win-win but this
topic comes after the extensive
examination i performed trying to
determine jinxed infinity which i think
went fairly well and gave us a whole ton
of insight into the character and how he
applies himself so as a result i wanted
to take this a step further and tackle
a much more complex puzzle being
paristan which starts with a pretty
tricky problem solve
being that to the best of our knowledge
we have not really seen a confirmed use
of nen from pariston
and this is very different to jing
because we did at least have examples of
him performing the art of a mission
meanwhile pariston's nenus is well it's
more speculative and interpretive
basically we do have two examples of
potential use but only in regards to
basic applications the first of which
would be a maybe invocation of ren
against cheadle during the whole
chairman election affair and now this is
much more obvious in the manga than the
anime because ren and i guess men in
general is portrayed very differently
across the two mediums
in the 2011 anime you would probably be
labelled as a kooka conspiracy theorist
for trying to read nenu's into this
scene but when we take a look at the
manga we have this very intriguing sound
effect being
voom actually it's not even that
vigorous it's more of a
which is short and heavily understated
but this is in keeping with the
depictions of ren in the series for
example take this panel of hisoka using
rend during the heavens arena arc with
the sound effect being
um and no it's not exactly the same but
something very cool about the hunt hunt
manga is that different characters
produce a different first syllable when
using ren
at least in the english translation
anyway but while it is not 100
confirmed as in literally stated by a
character or the author
this is a fairly clear example of
paristan using ren in a playful and
semi-threatening manner as is his style
continuing on the bren train though
shortly after in series jin confronts
paristan with an overtly clear use of
ren
and as you can see in jinx's case the
sound effect is like an
but in the bigger panel it looks like it
starts with a u again much like the
hisoka example
in any case the framing of aura is
surrounding jing and that makes it clear
that he is the one producing the bran
which means that paristan is almost
certainly using 10 to defend against it
which is reinforced by his comparatively
more peaceful and solid background
during the close-up
whilst jinx is violent and chaotic and
this quiet background of paristan will
become relevant later but i did just
want to point this out because the
overwhelmingly common belief amongst the
fanbase is that paristan has
never demonstrated nenu's which just is
not true he has not performed any hatsu
aka nan abilities but he has been shown
to be quite powerful and mastered
control of two of the basic principles
which is to be expected of a man in his
position but where do we go from here
without abilities to examine you'd think
we might be lost but we have two nen
tests that do not require the use of
specific abilities to determine an
affinity one of which is professor
hisoka's personality test which he
himself has admitted is relatively
unreliable but he subscribes to it
regardless and for the most part it does
seem to work out quite well and the
other would be the more recent advent of
furykov's new criteria which is oddly
specific but also incredibly vague
somehow at the same time and it doesn't
have a way of analyzing specialists but
it is very insightful nonetheless but
we're going to start with hisoka's
exploration and his definition of an
enhancer which are basically described
as mentally simplistic and incredibly
straightforward which if we were to take
this to heart
pretty much immediately disqualifies
paristan from this affinity barristan is
the complete antithesis of this
definition and in fact this man very
much prides himself on being
unpredictable
straightforward is not even a word that
exists in the lexicon of pariston hill
such a life would be beyond boring and
unlikely to be worth living to him and
so the only part of hisoka's examination
that does sort of fit paristan is that
he defines enhancers as profoundly
selfish
and possessing a laser-like focus on
their goals and even then paristan
doesn't necessarily evoke that
selfish yes sure but so is almost every
other character in the series and i
wouldn't necessarily call him laser-like
focused either because paristan is more
than willing to start up any number of
side quests just for the purposes of
having some fun and screwing around
not everything that paristan does is
some sort of three-dimensional chess
play
and he will often implement action
simply for the lols
he is a troll a supremely dangerous
troll and under this definition
there is no world where paristan hill
would be an enhancer so next let's jump
into manipulation which at face value
seems like a very friendly affinity for
paristan hisoka
starts by claiming that manipulators are
argumentative and logical which will
give at least one of those
characteristics to paristan i mean
calling him logical
is well it's debatable because once
again sometimes his actions will not go
towards serving a greater purpose
although when he does apply himself
paristan's shrouded logic is equaled
only by that of the genius jing himself
what really kind of turns me off
manipulation though is that they were
also defined as tending to want to keep
their family safe as well as loved ones
which works well for standard
manipulators in the series are like
illumi or kalatozoldik but
for pariston like the paristan hill i
mean it's almost worth completely
disregarding manipulation as a result of
this
barristan has no close friends or family
to our knowledge at least but what's
more paristan doesn't actually seem to
view anyone with that kind of special
relationship be they friend or foe
everyone pretty much holds the exact
same status in the mind of paristan
with the new exception of jing who
paristan has admitted that he is now
just now beginning to hate so no one is
precious to paris and furthermore
manipulation would probably be useless
to him because he can manipulate the
world enough with his mind as it is
no need for nan whatsoever so we'll skip
ahead to conjuration time now and going
into this i thought that other than
maybe specialization
this would be a pretty good fit for
paristan but like everything else so far
it presents a slight enigma hisoka
defines conjurers as highly strong
overly serious stoic and
nervous none of which applies to
paristan whatsoever as he is flippant
excessively chill
and perfectly in control at all times
there is no rattling paristan even jing
hasn't quite managed to break that yet
but the next part would be fairly
spot-on which is that conjurers are
always on guard
highly observant very logical and rarely
fall into traps
most of which pretty well defines
paristan he might not look it but he has
never been off guard in any appearance
he has made in the series and a lot of
that might just be due to his sheer
mental acuity but paristan is always
using his mind to its fullest there is
never a moment of relaxing his thought
process
and describing him as merely observant
does not do the character justice in any
way shape or form so while there is a
clear contradiction with the conjurer
definition this is definitely the
closest we've come so far to saying yeah
i guess that could be right
so let's see if we can get a bit closer
so onto transmutation which
starts out pretty damn strongly with
hisoka defining them slash himself as
whimsical prone to deceit and of course
fickle and this was the line that set
off alarm bells in me during the jing
video
because i think that's a fairly accurate
description of him however it is somehow
an even better characterization of
paristan
whimsical in particular is a beautiful
word because we've well and truly
established that facet of paristan by
now
he's obviously just a tiny bit prone to
a bit of the old deceit and as for
fickle while his attention does make
very sharp shifts on a regular basis and
you know it's something i've not really
thought about until
just before now but the personality
similarities between hisoka and paristan
are pretty incredible it's just that
with hisoka we have the advantage of
knowing exactly what his goal is whereas
peristance is still shrouded in mystery
or maybe paristan doesn't even have a
long-term goal maybe paristan is what
hisoka would have been
if he had no passion a truly terrifying
empty genius but none of the transmuted
definition goes on to contradict what we
know of paristan
and in fact a lot of it just repeats
itself by continuing to state that
transmuters make great efforts to hide
their abilities and intentions so with
this criteria alone i'd say that
transmutation is pretty bang on the
money here
we do still have two more to explore
though one of which is a mission which
is another completely counter-intuitive
affinity allegedly consisting of
individuals who are short-tempered and
not detailed oriented so you can think
leoria basically
and not quite paristan not quite
paristan at all even at his most
whimsical
barristan is eagerly analyzing every
last detail of the situation at hand and
hisoka's criteria basically goes on to
emphasize how impulsive emitters are
which you may think applies to paristan
because his actions certainly can seem
impulsive from the outside but even if
he's just playing a bit of a mental game
they are not his actions are very well
thought out so a mission seems highly
highly unlikely
and finally we have specialization users
of which are described as independent
and charismatic
another one that ranks some nice spells
with jing and it's going to do the same
for paristan because while those who
have to deal with paris and regularly
tend to despise him he does have this
innate ability to charm and gather
people around him whilst remaining
effectively independent which is another
specifically stated specialist trait
another being that they generally won't
say anything
of importance preferring to keep that
information to themselves which is
continuing to be pretty perfect really
it would be quite easy to see paristan
slipping into the slot of a specialist
but that is only according to one
examination and furykov tends to have
other ideas when it comes to name
classification and his criteria is
mostly about body language and
demonstrated use of 10. so this is where
the initial exploration of paristan's
menus may be
quite handy because furykov can divide
nen users into three broad categories
after recognizing the characteristics of
their ten the first of which is conjurer
exclusive apparently conjurers have this
habit of surrounding their favorite body
parts with a very strong layer of ten
whilst the rest of their bodies possess
a comparatively gentle layer and because
we only have a close-up of peristant to
deal with here i can't deny that it may
be possible that his tent is stronger
around a certain body part of choice
but what i can say is that it is
definitely quite gentle which becomes
more important with enhancers and
transmuters who according to furykov has
this almost perfect shroud of gentle 10
encasing them the more skilled they are
the logic being that straightforward
enhancers don't want to reveal their
favorite mechanism of attack
and for transmuters it's more of a
natural sneakiness and deceitful
practice
and this panel of powerstern is
definitely in keeping with that his 10
appears to be quite gentle and
consistent in the face of jinx casually
raging ren
so this feels like another potential win
for transmutation where emitters are
manipulated so furykov states that their
ten becomes darker whilst attempting to
hold it back
and paristan's aura is palpable here
although it is certainly not
dark but i suppose that could be
explained by him not making any effort
to attempt to hide it
if he was to be one of those affinities
it just doesn't feel
quite right though because i'm not sure
how easy it would be to hold back
against someone like jing
but at the same time as powerful as this
looks the two of them are almost
certainly still flirting with the idea
of conflict neither one of them has
gotten serious at this stage so it's
hard to determine what holding bacora
would mean oh and one more fun thing in
terms of body language apparently
conjurers tend to keep their dominant
hand by which i mean the most useful for
enacting their abilities free as much as
they can
which is certainly true of characters
like garappaka and with paristan he is
mostly seen occupying his right hand
however there are more than a few
examples of him occupying the left
so that can't really be used as a solid
gauge in this particular situation but
here we are now and i think that this
may end up being even easier to
determine than jinx affinity enhancement
is something that i think we can cross
off immediately
harrison just does not suit the uh the
simplistic mindset of a natural enhancer
and even though characters like netro
also break that trend
somewhat it's just not a realistic
affinity to play stock into at this
stage
emission is also being unceremoniously
dismissed because it fails hisoka's test
in every conceivable way and to pass
furykov's examination requires far too
much deep speculation
on that singular instance of 10 that we
have been privy to similarly
manipulation is going bye-bye
mostly because of the whole caring about
family and friends aspect but i also
mention this in the examination but it
would just be such a redundant affinity
for paristan to possess
manipulation is a super strong power for
those who are not naturally charismatic
and have need to control others whereas
paristan is perfectly capable of
manipulation without men
and yes that is kind of a lot of
personal speculation happening here but
there are undeniably stronger categories
of play
with conjuration paristan is a bit of a
50 50. this art form does tend to lend
itself towards the deeper thinkers of
hunt hunter and it cannot be
contradicted by the furykov criteria
but there is a distinct conflict in
hisoka's test about chondrus being stoic
nervous highly strong etc or that
business
and while i could certainly see paristan
being a conjurer it's much more of a
risk than we need to take
so conjuration is out so we are left
with two specialization and
transmutation both of which perfectly
suit paristan
although i really wish furykov had a way
to detect specialists so that we could
dive a bit deeper there but according to
hisoka paristan perfectly embodies the
characteristics of both of these
affinities and on a strictly
evidence-based examination i would have
to choose transmutation but there is
something so captivating about paristan
a certain quality that only grand
specialists in the series have displayed
think crollow merowem seradnik these
figures all have a certain oomph about
them which i think is very evident
within person and my personal belief is
that he would be a specialist
however due to the evidence at hand i
have to land on transmuter it could
definitely be either and i would most
certainly say that it is one of these
two over all the others but on this
occasion transmutation is going to win
the day
so if you did not choose that affinity
at the beginning of this video and i'm
afraid you need to take your punishment
and subscribe to the new world review
although with all this said i very much
look forward to eventually expanding a
bit more on the abilities
of paristan hill but what do you guys
think please do leave your thoughts in
the comments below or even join my
discord server and if you're keen for
some more hunt onto content then please
do feel free to check out my other
videos and even subscribe to the channel
for regular hunt hunter glory delivered
straight into your youtube feed but for
now this has been the new world review
and i'll see you next time